as you guys know chris ruffo lawyer had
him on the show a couple times
just one of the best this is a guy who
is so clearly uh
fighting critical race theory as i said
the other day there's a new meme out
there that no one can define
critical race they're either
conservative critics or critical race
there we can't define
critical race theory i've had rufo on to
define critical race there i've had
james lindsey on just last week
to define critical race theory i don't
need to get into all
of the jargon about critical race theory
but in essence if you want to teach
white children that they are born guilty
because of the color of their skin and
if you want to teach
people that the founding of america is
fundamentally racist
and that things as i keep saying like
being on time and working hard
and knowing that two plus two equals
four and having believing in empirical
evidence if you wanna
uh believe that those things are
actually
uh good things then you're a white
supremacist this is according to
critical race theory okay
uh so anyway chris ruffo is really
making headway because he's going from
state to state
and he's talking to the legislators he's
talking to the governors and some of the
mayors
and they're getting critical race theory
out of the schools meaning it won't be
taught there he's not banning the ideas
so everyone keeps saying it's an assault
on the first amendment no it's not
no it's and no one's saying that you
buffoons can't talk about critical race
theory all you want on msnbc and then
people like me can mock you
uh but that doesn't mean we should be
teaching it the same way i wouldn't be
for teaching say
nazism in school right you wouldn't want
to teach nazism but you can teach about
the nazis that would be something well
anyway whatever
whenever someone comes out there and
starts making a difference in the world
we know this
immediately you're going to get the hit
pieces the new york times is going to do
it
remember front page article about how
dave rubin leads people to the alt-right
through youtube yeah scary guy dave
rubin uh we know about this all the hit
pieces on jordan peterson and ben
shapiro anytime
anyone has anything interesting to say
that isn't sort of a brain dead leftist
progressive you're going to get massive
hit pieces
so the washington post roofo knew it was
coming the washington post went all in
and tried to destroy him so here is a
tweet
about the piece from author and
journalist
her name is laura meckler she says a
look at the important role
chris ruffo has played in sparking and
advancing the gop
fight against so-called critical race
theory
and how he in his words turned research
into a salient political issue with
a clear villain and now we'll show you
the headline of the article itself
and it's got a picture of chris ruffo
even in there and it's
uh the headline is republicans spurred
by
an unlikely figure see political promise
in targeting critical race theory okay
so so far it doesn't sound terrible now
they say
so-called critical race theory whenever
they want to besmirch something it's so
called right
well anyway i don't even need to read
the ridiculous article
to you or quote any of it because there
were so many errors in it
that rufo did the wise thing which is go
on the attack so this is just absolutely
beautiful this is a tweet
that ruffo sent out and an image about
the piece itself
and he wrote winning the washington post
hit piece against me has collapsed
they have admitted to fabricating a
timeline retracted
or added six full paragraphs reversed a
key claim
and failed to produce evidence on
falsified quotation democracy dies
when the media lies and then there's an
image there
the post admits that they fabricated the
timeline of a timeline of events
surrounding my involvement
in president trump's executive order
issuing a correction
at the bottom of the story the post was
forced to retract
two paragraphs and add four paragraphs
to the story reversing their reporting
on a key cupertino diversity seminar
which they had falsely claimed did not
occur
this reversal vindicates my reporting
post editor mike
semel admitted to me via email that the
newspaper does not have a recording or
transcript of a key quotation
that they falsified they claim the
reporter has
notes but cannot provide evidence to
support their original claim
post editor mike semele in an email that
virtually
all uh in an email that virtually all
white people contribute to racism
does not mean all white people are
racist this is an absurd position that
only an
ideologue could believe okay so you
don't
i get it there's a lot of information
there the point of this is not
uh to whittle down every mistake that
they made in every retraction literally
taking out two paragraphs putting four
more paragraphs
retracting a quote that they completely
made up and everything else the point
is fight back people not only fight back
but know just because you read something
in the washington post
does not mean it's true as a matter of
fact it's probably the reverse if you
read something
in the washington post it's probably a
lie if you read something
in the new york times it's probably a
lie and i'll go even further it's not
just
something it's specifically when they
attack a person
right because they do this all the time
i was on tour
with jordan peterson we were in europe
when there was a front
page piece written in the new york times
that jordan peterson was for enforced
monogamy and it was a very very scary
piece
and it was also when hans may tell was
out and it was the implication the way
it was written was very much like jordan
peterson wants to force women
to get married and then they'll
basically be sex slaves to pump out
units um and no that's not what he meant
what he meant was he liked the idea of
forced monogamy which in essence
is marriage meaning that marriage and
then the family unit is the basic
building block
of a functioning society which we all
kind of know
is true the author of that piece by the
way nellie bowles
is a former lefty who is now going
through a really interesting
political conversion i don't know if she
considers herself a conservative now i
think she still works
at the new york times but she's written
several pieces now
basically saying that she made a lot of
mistakes while she worked at the new
york times and i think she's still there
which is a little bizarre
but anyway the point is whenever they
write one of these things about a
specific person
just someone who's not woke who's doing
something good
you can basically say that that thing is
a lie
and again this all gets down to if you
have
friends that are reading these things
it's on you like if your little part of
saving the world
is waking your friends up to these
things and and going you know you know
next time you're at your house
you're at your friend's house let's say
on the weekend and you see they've got a
new york times
on the table there or they've got a
washington post on the table and they're
having coffee and it's like oh so you're
into the washington post
could you believe that that retraction
that they had to do on that guy chris
ruffo that was pretty nuts and they'll
go
what are you talking about and you go
well you're not going to believe it and
then you can actually you can send them
a clip
of this video or you can explain it
yourself or whatever it might be that's
how
we can fight back you know what i mean
we don't need to burn down everything
like they want to but i think that would
be
an effective way to do it